بيوت مهدمه وشوارع يملاها الدمار يعبر من
خلالها المواطنون بحثا عن الطعام
والامدادات الطبيه
رحله خطيره وشاقه في فتره الظهيره التي
يتباطؤ فيها القتال لتضع السودانيين بين
ناري الاقتتال وشح الغذاء والدواء وعند
الوصول الى وجهتهم النهائيه يتفاجا بان
غالبيه المحلات قد اغلقت ابوابها لتبدا
رحله اخرى من المعاناه
وضحايا شديد
والغنابل بتقع في خشم الباب
ونهب مسلح بصوره عشوائيه احنا دلوقتي جينا
وبيوتنا مش معروف عن القهوه ولا مش حنلقاز
وقت المسلحه
والدعم السريع
يرجع لصوت العقل ويحفظ دماء الشعب
السوداني السوداني والخرطوم بتمر
بوضع يعني اسوا من السيئين يعني حرب حرب
يعني والناس يعني مع اطفال ومخزي
للجانبين للجانبين
حدث ولا حرج
السكان في العاصمه السودانيه اضطر الى
التعامل والتفاوض مع طرفي النزاع وتحديدا
عند نقاط التفتيش بهدف الحصول على ممر امن
للعبور والعوده الى منازلهم فهم في نهايه
المطاف يعيشون جنبا الى جنب مع المقاتلين
الذين ينتشرون بالمدينه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات